mon travail officiellement donc
officieusement on travaille pas tout à
fait ça six jours sur sept oui on est
porté à quitter notre appartement à 6
heures du matin donc à 6 heures du matin
il faut qu'on soit déjà platon d'accord
maquiller coiffer habillé tout au taquet
et tout le temps on doit être au top ce
serait quoi le bon salaire pour sa puce
entre 6 et 7000 euros ah ouais grave
mais ça dit ouh là on n'est pas du tout
non c'est non non non vous êtes bien
optimiste d'accord ok mais dans les deux
trois mille euros à peu près si on fait
une fourchette ouais je tairai à peu
près alors il n'est pas l'odeur vaima la
match aller 1 3000 euros promis qu'ils
font en ce moment là donc ça vous semble
quoi vous ben moi ça me semble correct
je trouve pour le travail sachant que
tout est payé les déplace avec un fait
et puis c'est un conte de fées pascal il
ya tous les cadeaux c'est qu'elle a reçu
des clôtures etc ella ella qu'elle est
quand même couverte de cadeaux tout le
monde de l'art ça peut aller chez le
coiffeur gratuitement
et oui c'était mes impôts ont cessé je
sais que vous l'aimez bien cyrille m
elle adore c'est honteux
oui mais oui c'est sûr ils auront gardé
en moi j'ai un style mais qui ne rend
jamais ça et oui je sais c'est pas
franchement ils sont dès lors aux
seniors c'est paramount et deux parce
que faut arrêter berlin c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas audible en
revanche parce que là il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous qui nous regardent et qui
le 10 du mois sont déjà allés regarder
tout ça de la ville essentielle vers la
zone des jouets gagne 1300 euros en
travaillant fort et doux vélo masse elle
voulait parler de thaler oui non alors
moi je serais fait d'accord je suis gens
vont vous croyez dans une manif en tout
à fait ce que mes camarades disent mais
c'est vrai que je pense qu'elle a voulu
exprimer se sentiments dans le sens où
peut-être qu'elle a voulu dire que c'est
pas si tout beau tout rose voilà un rêve
que ça qu'il faut se réveiller qui a des
horaires c'est astrium voilà qui un
planning à respecter quand on
ne la fait pas
je suis d'accord avec m oui ben alors
maladroit merci oui moi je vais pas être
les mcdo comme gilles 3000 euros c'est
un très bon salaire certes c'est pas un
seul à exceptionnel non plus il ya un
fantasme sur les gens qui sont pas
connues et qui passe à la télé tous ne
pensent qu'ils sont millionnaires qui
sont richissimes ah désolé c'est pas
vrai et là c'est pendant que les miss
france mais la prémisse france ça peut
être encore plus dire s'il pourrait
arrêter de travailler ici voilà qui a
déjà assez de côté pour pouvoir arrêter
de travailler castanet nord mois non non
on va vous êtes obligé trop bas oui
j'oubliais pas plus m ainsi pas à nos
roger payet même pas même pas un compte
épargne ah ouais d'accord à rien
d'accord il y en a eu aussi bénévole
doit avoir de nom mais je peux pas
m'arrêter de travailler non non bien sûr
que non survie naïma et et ça fait des
années que vous travaillez sur tf1 sur
ces huit tout seul je connais vos
salaires mais et alors crois que cette
veste en cuir ou la vache savez quoi
situé à tabac non non non non bien sûr
que non monsieur oui j'ai travaillé
louis bien sûr kelly bien sûr comment
s'annonce mal peut pas non bien sûr non
mais je te parle moi la seule je pense
que si la bête m'a bien sûr que non
mais bien sûr que non d'abord moi je
demande jamais rien et je n'ai une
patrie ne serait-ce qu'un stylo à aucune
entreprise dans lesquels j'ai travaillé
non mais vous savez je paye tout plein
pot et d'un an et demi de l'argent de
côté sa non mon mari en mai parce que
justement il n'a pas confiance en moi ah
ouais
parce que vous croyez gérant pas ce
beaucoup et moi quand je passe de
l'argent je considère que c'est un don
un jeans ah non moi je pourrais pas
arrêter travail et je suis obligée de
travailler ici ou ailleurs mais chez
obligé de travail ça m'arrange pas sa
vie
boulet ben moi aussi je me jette
travailler j'ai une maison à payer comme
tout le monde
mais bien sûr j'ai bien j'ai gagné ma
vie il est passé de côté pour pour
arrêter mais c'est surtout montrer voilà
que c'est donc va tout oublié de
continuer à faire bien sûr a dit à moi
aussi je suis pas absolument obligé de
continuer à travailler
à lui les
gens sont las de la réserve alors il
doit travailler
vous racontera
vous pourriez
pour ce que dilma lama moi j'aime bien
rigoler moi j'adore mais si d'abord la
raison c'est c'est un business man bien
ce comité miss france à badens des fois
il ya des gens qui gagnent de l'argent
sur flu non ils se sont dit pourquoi
n'auraient pas un peu plus d'argent ce
n'est pas scandaleux mais les démagogues
et termine beaucoup d'argent 3000 euros
mais parce que vous êtes des grandes et
beaucoup on n'est pas tellement démago
mais la vérité c'est qu'au effectivement
elle fait bosser beaucoup de gens et
feliz año comité miss france voilà qui
est une entreprise privée il n'y a rien
de ce qu'elle a dit est un peu plus
du tout parce qu'une fois que l'année
passée où tout est payé chaque fois
qu'elle se déplacera quelque part pour
le moindre gallas et 3000 euros qu'elle
touchera pas ces gars-là revêt donc les
miss france n'ont pas à se plaindre
voilà